quand on parle d'internet on évoque
souvent le risque du piratage voire pire
l'introduction d'un virus dans les
réseaux pour s'en prémunir il existe
désormais une école spécialisée
elle forme des pirates qui seront rompu
à toutes les techniques
sophie rodier eric de l'agneau salut
arnaud el assel riser 21 ans pirates
blanc il ne porte pas le bandeau des
corsaires de naguère
pourtant dans le jargon des
informaticiens arnaud est un pirate
blanc comprenez un défenseur de
l'internet
son objectif combattre les hackers qui
s'infiltrent frauduleusement dans les
réseaux et il le sait bien la sécurité
sur le web est loin d'être parfaite
problème je m'en rappelle plus de mon
mot de passe ce qui est magique avec
l'informatique et avec windows sais que
je vais pouvoir retrouver mon mot de
passe sont sans le connaître
avec un petit utilitaire très simple
qu'on trouve n'importe où sur internet
il est facile de le décrypter presque un
jeu d'enfant
inutile d'être un génie de
l'informatique pour faire sauter un code
d'accès il suffit de lire la presse
spécialisée regardez vous acheter des
magazines très sérieux et très réputé
vous pouvez devenir a à coeur ce sans
problème ici on voit
prenez le contrôle total d'un pc à
distance alors avec ça vous êtes tous
des hackers c'est interdit mais certains
n'hésitent pas à utiliser ses logiciels
pour protéger ses données
arnaud ses découpes de sécurité
informatique dans cette école une école
de pirates qui a pignon sur vous
officiellement
ici on se contente d'apprendre à se
protéger des hackers malveillants
non sans quelques recommandations c'est
à dire que vous pouvez pas vous amuser
sur internet à faire dans ce caniveau
envoyé vétroz gens c'est totalement
illégal
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens vont
venir à la base ils vont venir pour
essayer de comprendre essayer de se
sécuriser et forcément il y aura
toujours des gens qui sont là pour
hacker pas ce qu'ils vont voir écrit en
gros à coeur il
il pense que on va leur apprendre à pied
tous les systèmes possibles en six mois
l'école a formé ce 450 élèves aux
profils variés lycéens informaticien et
même aux policiers
pour ceux qui seraient tentés de tricher
la loi est claire un an de prison et
15000 euros damende salut arnaud lsl
riser 21 ans pirates blanc allaient ils
ne portent pas le bandeau des corsaires
de naguère % dans le jargon des
informaticiens et un pyrale et blanc
voilà comprenez un défenseur de
l'internet
son objectif combattre les hackers qui
s'infiltrent frauduleusement dans les
réseaux et il était bien la sécurité sur
le web est loin d'être parfaite
problème je m'en rappelle plus de mon
mot de passe ce qui est magique avec
l'informatique et avec windows sais que
je vais pouvoir retrouver mon mot de
passe sont sans le connaître
avec un petit utilitaire très simple
qu'on trouve n'importe où sur internet
il est facile de le décrypter tu
souffres est un jeu d'enfant inutile
d'être un génie de l'informatique pour
faire sauter un code d'accès il suffit
de lire la presse spécialisée regardez
vous acheter des magazines très sérieux
et très réputé et vous pouvez devenir un
hacker ce sans problème
ici on voit prenez le contrôle total
d'un pc à distance alors avec ça vous
êtes tous des hackers
le but a fuité sur internet
c'est à dire que vous pouvez pas vous
amuser sur internet à faire dit stany
vous envoyer vétroz gens c'est
totalement illégal
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui vont
venir à la base ils vont venir pour
essayer de comprendre essayer de se
sécuriser et forcément il y aura
toujours des gens qui sont là pour
hacker parce qu'on voit écrit en gros à
coeur et ils vont pour qu'ils pensent
qu' on va leur apprendre à qui tous les
systèmes possibles ce qui s'est passé